devil fruits have a will of their own
that can be inherited through the
generations which is exactly why the
gomu gomonomi is so important now same
as you you probably have been very
focused on haki for the past couple of
years which just makes sense this may
sound harsh but devil fruit simply were
not that interesting for a while until
doflamingo revealed the next level
awakening and minus spoiler since this
topic has become relevant again in
recent chapters with the revealed
awakenings of kit and law i couldn't
help but wonder has luffy awakened his
devil fruit as well what would it
actually look like and most importantly
what is the secret behind the fruits in
the first place for the first time in a
while that really got me thinking to the
point where i was lying in bed at night
unable to sleep my analytical brain
shifting into overtime gear told me that
there just had to be some clues in the
story i simply had to know so what did i
do well what any reasonable person would
do at 4 am in the morning i got up open
my laptop and started working i was
gonna analyze every type of fruit every
piece of lure and every instance of
awakening until a few hours later i
actually managed to complete this crazy
puzzle of clues that connects luffy
roger and joy boy but i'm getting ahead
of myself here hi my name is manu my
favorite fruit is pineapple and in this
video i will pull back the curtain for
you on the true nature of devil fruits
because the devil truly lies in the
details here the first thing i did as i
usually do with any theoretical analysis
was to establish the facts what do we
actually know and even though you're
probably familiar with all of this it's
gonna be critical for the juicy bit
later on and let's be real there's
definitely less fun things than learning
some facts about devil fruits okay so
baseline is these fruits seem to have
been around for a long time and have
become a regular part of the one piece
world while they're considered quite
rare and special on the grand line that
attracts only the strongest and weirdest
people they're found on a much more
common basis
[Music]
there are three types of devil fruits
each with their own subcategories
pineapple banana and orange just
checking if you're still paying
attention zone fruits allow their users
to transform into an animal giving them
access to their regular form their
animal form as well as a hybrid form
subcategories include ancient zones for
animals that have gone extinct like
dinosaurs mythical zones that include
mythical creatures like the phoenix as
well as a separation into herbivore and
carnivore types boosting endurance and
defense or speed and offense
respectively
next are logia fruits they're pretty
easy to summarize as you know a low gear
turns the body of its user into an
element for example fire regular
physical attacks are useless here and
this is little known but logia users can
actually enhance their powers
significantly by subscribing to my
channel for next generation anime
concepts paramecia fruits then are the
dumping place for all powers that don't
fit in the other two categories and
there are a ton of subcategories here
some users can enhance their bodies
luffy's enhancement is permanent for
instance he's a rubber man mr one can
transform his body at will while someone
like brook only gets the effect of his
fruit through a certain event in this
case death
other users are able to produce a power
some can produce materials like
doflamingo's string others can produce a
force of nature like whitebeard
while again others can produce entire
worlds of their own such as mondor or
brule lastly there are people who i
guess basically do magic there's people
like sugar who can manipulate living
things people who have control over a
certain space like law and corazon and
some even crazier powers like big mom's
soul manipulation
in general there are four known
weaknesses to devil fruit powers first
and maybe most dangerous is losing the
ability to swim if a user is submerged
into water they are drained of all
energy and incapable of moving or using
their powers which in a world of pirates
consisting to 99 of water is a pretty
damn big handicap simply throwing a
glass of water at them won't work though
probably the next best thing though is
sea prism stone which is mined in wano
and comes with its own set of mystery of
how it's actually made and why it really
works
[Music]
the end result however is that this
material has the same essence as the
ocean which is white can be used to take
out an ability user even on land and
without throwing that glass of water at
them third is haki more specifically
armament hockey or as it's called in
french aqui de la memo montieux this can
be used to forcibly turn a devil fruit
user's body back into regular flesh and
bones no matter how it was transformed
or shaped and i never really thought
about it for some reason but isn't it
really strange that haki has this effect
on devil fruits well small tease here
this is going to be one of the details
in which the devil will be found later
better put on some pants devil fourth
and this will also play a role there is
one devil fruit out there that has the
ability to absorb and nullified any
other power blackbeard's yummy yummy
know me that he calls the strongest
logia out there
the most recent thing we learned is that
devil fruits can actually be awakened
basically by mastering one's ability and
being able to fully control it at will
the user starts to unlock a new level to
his fruit that in some way or form
enhances its power or reach zone users
generally get access to a giant
monster-like hybrid form that boosts all
their physical attributes and also lets
them recover very quickly from even the
most fatal attacks
examples of this are the guards in impel
down as well as most likely chopper's
monster points now while we haven't seen
a loga user officially awaken it is
pretty safe to assume that such a power
permanently changes the environment
around them this is not only based on
doflamingo's explanation but also on how
the landscape on punk hazard was
permanently changed after the battle
between aokiji and the kainu as well as
raijin island that suspiciously looks
like someone went a bit cray-cray with
annals fruit there as well
lastly we have the wide range of
paramecia users while producers like
dofi kid and katakuri are able to change
their environment as well as their body
in their waking state someone like law
seems to get additional abilities for
his fruit like creating shock waves
inside the opponent's body and actually
i think there is a pretty good chance
that luffy's awakening has already
happened if you want me to talk about
that as well let me know so now that i
had established all that we knew about
devil fruits and consumed two cups of
coffee it was time to go clue hunting
okay so there are a couple of things
that got me wondering about the true
nature of devil fruits and if there
wasn't more to all of this without
making it any more unnecessarily
dramatic i was wondering whether devil
fruits were in some weird way or form a
life
[Applause]
while the idea of a sea devil residing
in each fruit might have seemed like a
casual sailor talk in early one piece
shanks turned out to be one of the most
well-informed connected and powerful
people in the story and i've already
talked in other videos a lot about how
shanks most likely was not simply
chilling around in the east blue but
actively following roger's will to find
the man he was waiting for so my thesis
statement is going to be that this
explanation by shanks to buggy on board
of roger's ship is literal there recites
a devil inside every fruit that is then
transferred into the body of the person
that consumes it and merges with their
soul let me try and prove it to you
first of all we have the incarnation of
devil fruit powers when a fruit user
dies his ability is shown to leave the
body like a soul and travel to the
nearest fruit of the same type for
example smiley zone type fruit would
always be an apple which is why there
can be a devil fruit encyclopedia in the
first place that blackbeard used to
identify the yami yaminumi imagine if it
suddenly was a banana
the soul leaves the host and finds its
next container once someone takes a bite
of this new fruit the devil enters the
body and the rest of the fruit is
useless well except for vitamins which
are important basically your soul and
the soul of the devil merge on nslobby
jabra explains to us that two devils
would fight if you try to consume a
second devil fruit killing the user in
the process the biggest evidence that
devil fruits have a will of their own
however in my opinion are funk frite
smiley and the second goodest boy in one
piece lasso
to the best character in all of media
and that character is whitebeard
dog whitebeard's dog all three of them
are objects a sword a gas weapon and a
gun that have gained consciousness free
will and the ability to turn into an
animal the only explanation really is
that the soul contained in the devil
fruit is transferred into the object
pretty much the successful version of
what caesar tried to do with the smiles
these objects now understand human
speech and even have a will of their own
as is shown in this scene here
[Music]
and if they actually have their own will
that also gives us an answer as to why
devil fruits have their respective
weaknesses if the sea devil grants these
powers he could just absorb them back
once you sink into him his will is
stronger than yours and that of your
smaller devil similarly hockey is able
to overcome a fruit not because it
overcomes the will of the owner but of
the devil fruit itself otherwise every
time someone tried to use haki on
another user they would be stuck in
limbo fighting it out for a while before
they could actually forcibly change
their bodies back as for blackbeard if
his devil fruit truly is the strongest
devil fruit and i have to admit that
darkness fruit seems like the most
devilish one out there that would mean
that the devil in his fruit is stronger
than any other devil and that it
nullifies their abilities in the very
same way awakening a devil fruit then
could be a quite literal phrase when
you're underwater your devil is asleep
in your everyday state the devil is in
something of a dream state sharing their
abilities but when you awaken the full
potential of the devil is unleashed with
the awakening the devil part of your
soul would of course become stronger
which is exactly what we see in the
prison guards in impul down
[Applause]
they are much more animal than human
just as with chopper who has to train
hard to get control over the state as
well people like doflamingo and katakuri
clearly have control over it but
nonetheless all the awakened fruits we
know of cause incredible destruction to
their surroundings and are really hard
to keep in check you're literally
fighting with the devil over control
[Music]
and they also require an enormous amount
of energy and seeing how kit and laws
struggle with it congress hockey might
well play a role and be an advantage in
dealing with this state doflamingo and
katakuri after all both were able to use
their awakening quite creatively and
really bend the rules of their normal
powers but what comes next is what you
probably have been waiting for and it
will hopefully really blow your minds
when i realized it i definitely could
see a light turning on above my head it
felt like luffy was watching over me
thanks to the awesome sponsor of today's
video the awesome people over at weep
lamp who sent me these fantastic custom
anime lights each of them can be
illuminated in 16 different colors and
four different modes and i personally
like to dim mine down a little bit for
that really nice ambient kind of feel
they look fantastic on my shelf and are
actually the perfect addition to the
video background i'm trying to build
here not only do they have tons of great
options on their website already but you
can even custom order your own lamp from
whatever anime or manga you want and
kindly enough they were even willing to
give you guys a 15 discount when using
the code o'hara at checkout okay so i'm
gonna tell you that the devil's soul not
only merges with your own it also takes
on some of your properties in other
words devil fruits are used to inherit
someone's will let me get you through
this the best example case here is ace
and his mera meranomi sabo mentions that
they have to get back his fruit so that
they can inherit that person's will
similarly blackbeard who tried
recruiting ace into his crew before
capturing him tells luffy that burgess
will take the fruit and it'll be as if
ace had joined himself
[Music]
however it could be that they're just
talking about his legacy but when sabo
eats the fruit and blows away burgess he
says this really strange line
and even more strangely i found that
sabo started acting like ace even the
way he says goodbye was the same as ace
did on alabaster
and just a bit later sabo goes off on
his own at marijua and potentially gets
captured just like ace but you might
rightfully say that might just be
because him and ace were really close
well here is exhibit number two big mom
and mother caramel we do know for a fact
that lin lin was an extremely kind and
caring kid that at times lost control
trying to do good things however after
consuming mother caramel's fruit
she starts turning evil and took on many
of caramel's traits she starts calling
herself big mom has the same devilish
smile and lipstick and while mother
caramel was using the orphans for her
benefits big mom uses her own children
for hers the same is true for the
weapons that consume fruits they all
take on certain personalities and a
really interesting example is actually
khalifa she was introduced as this
incredibly serious woman but once she
ate her devil fruit she started doing
things like this
similarly blackbeard suddenly wants to
be called admiral after eating his fruit
and two other really interesting people
in this category are actually
bartholomeo and mr two both of them as
we know are very kind and gentle people
at heart but while mr two joined
crocodile's dark scheme to overthrow an
entire country bartolomeo is known to be
very cruel to those outside the straw
hats did you also ever find that a bit
strange well now that we know that both
of these roots belong to the kudozumi
clan if they had inherited their cruel
and scheming ways that would make sense
right
[Music]
but the real mind blow to me was
applying this to luffy for some strange
reason the gomu gomonomi turned out to
be way more important than we actually
thought it was stolen and protected by
shanks who got into a conflict with the
world government about it i've always
hated the idea that raja had ate the
gomo gomonomi as well but looking at it
through this lens what if he had and
luffy literally took on some of roger's
personality traits as you know so many
characters have drawn parallels between
luffy and roger down to luffy saying the
exact same thing as the first pirate
king
luffy's reaction at his execution in low
town roger luffy's reason to look for
the one piece roger and it's only after
luffy eats the gomugomonomi that he
declares his dream to become pirate king
for the very first time to shanks upon
which he then receives roger's old hats
[Music]
oh wait if that were true shouldn't we
already know that roger has had the same
fruit as luffy that should be common
knowledge after all but what if it was
actually joy boy's fruit now this is
admittedly speculation but what if roger
found this fruit on love tale consumed
it inherited joyboy's will and then died
a little later without most people ever
knowing for his execution as we know
knives and blades still work on luffy so
wouldn't it make a lot of sense that
this was the true reason this fruit was
special not because it had some secret
rubber power but because it has joy boys
and rogers inherited will in it and
remember roger's last words to rayleigh
[Music]
he literally remembers them after
meeting luffy
this theory is based on a lot of
analysis but if you want something even
bigger i suggest you check out the best
one piece theory ever right